do you love odd one out
did you know that every purchase at the
jubilee shop helps fund this show
if you're looking for ways to support
jubilee and watch more episodes of odd
one out make sure you check out our
merch at shop.jubileemedia.com
now enjoy this episode
let's talk about what animal goofy is
okay
that's like a species i always go to
dogs right i mean yeah and he's
attracted to a cow
we brought together seven disney fans
i'm a disney fan i'm a disney fan i'm a
disney fan i'm a disney fan i am a
disney fan i'm a disney fan i'm a disney
fan
one is a liar if the group discovers a
deliar is they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who
is the odd one out
do people really think about that
so i was like okay i guess they do whoa
mine is actually
a little bit of silver age but
everyone was wearing like super spirited
disney things the only one who stood out
to me the most was lavender she had a
more dark like attire what's everyone
really favorite disney princess i love
tiana ariel
yeah look at that i'm wearing it
and it's not a stereotype i swear my
favorite princess is vanellope okay
how do we feel about the live action
[Laughter]
i was like watching two dogs fall in
love and i was like interesting
interesting
and i was like i am uncomfortable
[Music]
jamal was a little quiet he was more
agreeing with people than actually
giving answers to the questions
when i looked at aya i was like there's
just something
something's off about this
[Music]
we have a tie
the tie is between eric
and aya
we're going into a tiebreaker where each
of you will tell us your disney hot tape
and why
okay my hot take is disney does not
treat its employees right i feel like
the kobe pandemic was like the biggest
example of that they like laid off all
their employees they like didn't pay
them feels morally wrong to like support
that even though like you're really
supporting like the creatives and the
people behind the magic that are like
working on it they're discontinuing like
the annual passes for disneyland when i
was finally gonna buy one yeah because
they're only having it for like annual
pass holders from before or their kids
if they're like old enough now and i was
like okay like post pandemic i'm gonna
go to disney pass i'm gonna actually be
able to go because i'm not in school
anymore and like
i wish i had a little bit more chance to
like prove the stuff that i knew i got
disney ink on me so like 100 i think
this would have proved that i'm a
die-hard disney fan let's talk about
what animal goofy is
okay
okay the age of goose
species okay like the confusion is like
between that if he's like a dog or a cow
right because if he's a dog then how is
pluto like an actual he's like
exactly what would you say like goofy
movies what did you say i always go with
a dog right i mean yeah and he's
attracted to a cow but like you know
it's just one of those things that we're
expected as kids to accept and yeah i
worked at disneyland for three years up
until the layoff so when people would
ask me is uh max goofy
dog or what and i tried to say like
because that's what they would tell us
to say that he's a goof vanessa had
mentioned that she was a cast member and
you know which is an easy easy way for
you to learn disney facts and disney
things like i saw like with eyes that
chester was sussing me out like hard i
wanted to work at the happiest place on
earth what's everyone's favorite disney
song so i won't say i'm in love by mega
when i saw her singing it i was like oh
okay maybe i'm a little bit uh
it's actually a song from pocahontas
that they pulled out because they
thought it was totally don't do it
which is like quintessential
like just all-encompassing disney i feel
like every hardcore disney fan knows
where the human skull is
i didn't know about the human skull i
didn't know there was a human skull
never heard of it do you guys collect
anything disney yes i like the haunted
mansion figurines oh
they're like expensive ones that break
my bank
i collect fabric and the funko pops do
you make things with a fabric yes i make
bags backpacks purses wallets like all
the things maybe it could be her because
she could just be someone who does this
for a living and so she's familiar with
the market has everyone been to disney
world or disneyland disneyland
i've actually never been to either
because i'm from chicago and like it's
so expensive jamal had said i've never
been to disneyland i'm like what it's
understandable it is pretty expensive
never been a straight person you like
disney
really i have oh dang girl
literally i haven't met a lot of
straight
[Laughter]
she said that she was like a 90s disney
fan 90s was like when disney was like at
its biggest so it would be just like the
easiest thing to know about
i voted for lavender because her body
language was kind of saying like i don't
want to be here i don't know what i'm
doing here
and we have a tie
the tie is between
jamal
and lavender
we're going to a tiebreaker where each
of you will tell us what is your
favorite disney movie and why
this is hardest question you can ask
disney fan um but i
love lady and the more than
anything i love the cartoons i love the
score one of my favorite singers does
like the main song lalaloo
lalaloo
and i've called like every girlfriend
that i've ever had dove
because of that movie
okay my favorite movie is frozen is
probably cliche but i think it's just
such a beautiful story the music is
amazing and i think disney does a good
job of subverting the classic prince
falls in love with princess they fall in
love but the true love in this story is
more between the sister elsa and anna
and i think that's really beautiful also
i'm a huge rally fan and frozen on stage
is amazing
[Music]
thank you guys
bye
i thought i did good but i feel like
everyone says frozen is their favorite
movie so it is what it is
please raise your hand if you want to
continue the game in three
two
one
i'm like i think that we're all fans can
we just stop the game
this will be the magical experience
round
each of you will get the opportunity to
tell the others what was your most
magical experience with disney
i grew up like super poor and the only
time i got to go to disney was with my
like rich grandpa i was adopted into my
family and
so i didn't really like have a
relationship with anyone like but my
oppa it was really great like
integrating into the family and also
like building a relationship with my
oppa
um and he just died last year so going
without him is still it feels like he's
still with me so even just going is like
magical when i first started driving i
got a speeding ticket and i was pulled
over by the police i freaked out and i
was so nervous that when he was like
licensed and registration i like reached
over and i grabbed my wallet i just
handed him everything i carry my like
autotopia license the first one i ever
got in my wallet and i had it in front
of my license and he looked at it and he
let me go so i come home and i'm like oh
my god i got out i'm speeding ticking
she's like how and i'm like disney
so as you guys know i worked at
disneyland but i was never super
specific what i did i was in the
entertainment department and i would uh
watch and hang out with the characters a
lot there were moments where i'd cry
because seeing these families together
was just so beautiful and i have like
picture photographic memories of this
and
i'm really grateful for that so i as
well have a lot of magical disney
memories um some of my own and then some
of them from my son i would take him to
disneyland all the time like i was able
to afford us a a yearly pass and there
was one time
i bought him a balloon like the balloon
broke off and he's like like he got so
depressed and sad well i guess i'll buy
you another one like they're kind of
expensive but you know i'll do it oh can
i buy another one he's broke they're
like oh no problem and like they just
gave him one for free i'm just like
it wasn't until like i saw
fireworks set to music for the very very
first time i think it was believe i
think is what it was
one of the first ones i actually went
with friends and this was like the first
time i had ever gone
without
like family i think about it all the
time like me and my four best friends
from high school all i remember is being
there and just feeling absolutely happy
i didn't know who to vote for
i feel really bad kyra i'm sorry
i voted for kira i thought that maybe
she's just a disney mom not a disney fan
[Music]
no
me
okay
if you want to continue playing the game
please raise your hand in three
two one
i still had a sneaking suspicion that it
was vanessa the fact that she was a cast
member and it's very easy for you to get
that information because it's ingrained
in the training you know there are a lot
of us that don't like where we work so
you know who knows
if it's one of yours
if the lights turn green that means you
have voted out the mole and you all win
if the light turns red that means the
mole is still in the box and you lose
it's you no
okay now it's personal now it's personal
i had suspicion
will the mole please step forward and
reveal yourself in three
two
one
i am so sorry
[Applause]
i'm a disney the company hater as the
mole uh i might have peed myself a
little bit
i mean the character who like i was
that's like one of my friends who's like
a fanatic
emulating basically i like don't like
disney as a company and i like to stand
behind what i believe in you know when
you have so much influence over children
i kind of wish that you'd prioritize
like making the children's life like so
much happier than like the money behind
it aya deserves an oscar
like she had fully done the work i think
she earned that money i mean i get down
to go to disneyland with everyone
for me being a disney fan is not
necessarily about loving the company
itself but enjoying and connecting to
the content that they put out there it
really brings out the child at heart
whenever i go to disneyland i feel
like a kid again as a company there's a
lot to not like about it but really
disney's like about the cast members the
imagineers like the people behind the
magic and like i love everything about
that i'm gonna take these off real quick
because i don't deserve to wear them
this looks kind of bad
i'll i'll invest it in like disney
something
okay i'll get back